[Music]
to me Mario
what who lets ago okie-dokie oh I've
been the voice of Mario for 26 years now
I gotta we do hi I'm Charles Martin a I
do the voice of Super Mario Luigi
nevermind Oh Mario hey buddy yeah oh you
gonna eat that garlic
yeah and I was even Donkey Kong one boy
oh I am an actor and voice actor I did
gosh 25 years of theater corporate
videos a circuitry and semiconductor
processes a few film and television
products now beat it all you know and
then that I had the marvelous beginning
of becoming a voice actor and that's how
I started with E to me Mario Mario was
first created in 1981 in a game called
Donkey Kong as it got refined through
the years it became Mario and Princess
Peach PTAs and I came along in 1990 I
actually crashed an audition because I
was catching them as I walked in they
were walking out finished for the day I
said can I read for this and the guy
looked at his watch and goes all right
come on in you're an Italian plumber
from Brooklyn a character in a video
game for Nintendo called Mario so make
up a voice make up a video game start
talking and I thought to myself video
game I don't know anything about video
games and all of a sudden I hear action
I go hello I'm a Mario let's make a
pizza by together you will get some
sausage I'll get some spaghetti we put
spaghetti in the sausage in the pizza
and he said you know cut stop talking
there's no more tape all right thanks
we'll be in touch and I thought that was
you know okay there's the door we'll see
you later and
he calls Nintendo I found out Mario I
got him and that was 26 amazing
fantastic years ago oh look at this for
the character for me brings out the best
in me and so I love that I love sharing
things too I go to meet Mario fans and I
hear the most wonderful thing you know
the you're the voice of my childhood you
know I used to play with my dad now I'm
playing with my kids you know and we
just it's a way our family comes
together the memories yeah you just have
fun you know that's my mantra for life
come on let's go
it's have more fun bye-bye see you in my
Games's
all right Tara in this one rocky said a
mountaintop he gets swatted by the
monster tail he falls tumbles and rolls
and falls up another ledge falls another
bunch of budget feats and then crashes
alright watch my hands I'll watch you
here comes the perfect my name is Tara
Strong and I'm mostly known for my
animation career I'm the voice of Timmy
Turner from The Fairly OddParents Raven
from Teen Titans Azarath metrion zinthos
originally I was Batgirl alongside Mark
Hamill and Kevin Conroy I've had a
really fun career and that was one tough
montage so I knew to me had to be happy
mischievous silly kinda nerdy
oh it's very very adventurous bubbles
had this weird way of pronouncing things
like Oh
like I don't know why it goes Elly like
that but yeah the time I booked Rugrats
I just got off a plane of the screaming
baby and I'm like that's the cry that
I'm doing and most of Dill's lines were
in the stage directions so I'd be like
okay and I was like my lines I remember
at the session we had to stop tape and
I'm thinking something's wrong and they
said Tara there's a new mom in the
studio and you're making her lactate and
you guys say I'm not funny but seriously
this will be extremely painful in the
case of Raven while I was doing the
audition it was similar to my own voice
and
just this idea dava's weird got a little
role every time she says anything as
soon as I started doing this I saw the
people in the booth kind of look at each
other and went that's Raven Robin stop
Batgirl was me like it's the only voice
I do that's my own voice that was
Batgirl Bullwinkle it's like that
classic story the line and the mouse
that we're ripping off when your voice
acting you have to tap into the ability
to make something believable without it
being there it's a completely different
art form than on-camera you have to let
the audience to feel what it's like to
fall off a cliff without there actually
being a cliff they're like you gotta
have to be willing to play around and
not afraid to look silly and then once
you create a character in my experience
they like live up in my brain and
they're just ready to come down when
it's our turn so I don't confuse them
they all are their own entity basically
I'm a crazy person
so I just need a long scream as you just
keep going
[Music]
we need we need the store garbage bags
[Music]
[Music]
in a world where cat videos and means
rule the beads one media company will
rise above the noise this is great big
story okay right that's great thank you
got it yeah that's great cool
you can still speak about that now
though what do you mean this is how I
always speak my name is red pepper I'm a
voice-over artist in the UK are voiced
hundreds of movie trailers men in black
saving the earth from the scum of the
universe Blair Witch Project
Armageddon Space Jam mr. Venus holiday
so many I forget half of them to be
honest with you I started doing
television adverts animations audiobooks
I'll do a lot of video games as well and
a lot of them are sound effects of
ghouls in the background when I first
started doing movie trailers there was
um that was fun one man coming soon to a
cinema near you or sometimes I do
romantic movies in a sleepy town
sometimes I'm doing horror don't answer
the door you gotta use your voice you
got a reason sometimes and you gotta
take it to the depths very occasionally
I get recognized but generally no but at
the time I do get recognized phone goes
off in the Train guaranteed hello and
people look up from behind the
newspapers the way I got into being a
voice artist was kind of strange
I used to drive trains on the London
Underground one morning I was making my
announcements all sessions to narrow my
tours a television executive was a
passenger on my train he got off of the
next stop ran up to my cab the exchange
details and the rest is history
I've had some strange experiences as a
bullet soreness I was the Metatrader for
Jurassic Park the lost world seemed a
Spielberg movie and kindly they chose me
to do the voice in the UK
something is coming something big and as
I said that a voice in my headphones
said wow that's a great voice and I
didn't recognize it was Steven Spielberg
he was listening in from the states into
London will I swore I said Who though is
that everybody went crazy in the studio
No
Spielberg oh sorry I appreciate what I
do I'm still meticulous about what I do
I'm so proud of what I do
I really don't look at it as a job I'm
having fun it really is a cool job it's
got to be up there with one of the
coolest jobs on the planet right you got
it go I'm out of here
as far as my resume you you don't know
me but you know Tigger and Winnie the
Pooh I think it goes something like this
but I can only do it for a small micro
love honey I'm Tigger don't be
ridiculous
Tigger's are wonderful things their tops
are made in a rubber the bottom of the
middle of Springs you got to pay for the
rest with you well you know at the way I
got into the industry I mean I guess I
was kind of doing research my whole life
because I'd be sitting in the back of
the classroom and you know I thought it
was time to break out a dolphin I don't
want to say I was the class clown I was
the class wit cuz it sounds better some
of the characters I play as a voice
actor I dig my orders directly from Java
princess I want you to do is trust the
woman's like a man with a big back port
some kind of get come here you little
right off people said well which ones
most like you and I probably darkwing
duck cuz he's a wise guy well I am the
terror that flaps in the night I am the
bug that splatters across the windshield
of crime I and the Queen duck what could
be more important than a little
something to eat well you know as far as
performing Pooh we have to be true to
the character while I always say that
who sees the world through honey colored
glasses not a bad way to go
somebody or something honey I juggle a
say that I'm Winnie the Pooh in the ante
poo because I'm the Tasmanian Devil too
as like
[Music]
having a little trouble a lot of times
my agent will get in touch with me and
there'll be a special needs little boy a
little girl were on the telephone and
they're talking to Pooh or Tigger but
his response was it's just so cute he's
in the world you know Tigger was alive
and talking to him to know that you can
bring him into a smile bill and and
where everything's happy and you're it's
it's just a blessing and a half I never
take it for granted honestly the most
rewarding part is seeing people's
reactions and hearing stories about how
this one song got them through tough
times and they they'll go back and
they'll listen to wherever you are a
song that Winnie the Pooh song
cause without you one totally
I'm grateful grateful every day
[Music]
you